[Musique]
Charles Rodwell bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir alors votre permanence à
Versailles absolument de débutant des
députés de la première circonscription
des Yvelines on a beaucoup de questions
à abordées on va revenir évidemment sur
ce qui s'est passé l'Assemblée nationale
avec le débat sur les retraites puisque
dans quelques mois vous arrivez votre
première anniversaire de député donc
nous a rencontré comment vous avez vécu
ce débat on reviendra évidemment sur la
forme de retraite sur peut-être les
réformes que vous souhaitez parce que
c'est un claqué dans la peau particulier
puisque le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron ne pourra pas se
représenter à l'issue de ce Bourdin
on parlera aussi de votre rôle de député
de cette première conscription et puis
d'une mission dont vous avez été
rapportée sur sur les exportations sur
l'exportation pour aller vite on va
avoir parlé parce que c'est intéressant
première question donc on va revenir sur
ces débat les Français ont vu regarder
un peu cette Assemblée nationale très
divisé parfois très violente avec des
actes d'ailleurs qui ont été sanctionnés
des agents comme le robergers vous
parlez de spectacle à frison parfois
comment vous l'avez vécu vous ce débat
parce que c'est vrai que cette violence
qui a existé dans l'histoire politique
il y avait un moment quand même qu'elle
n'était pas aussi forte son utile c'est
sûr que
dans le débat sur la réforme des
retraites on a passé un cap un câble de
l'indécence de la part des deux extrêmes
de l'hémicycle
avec d'un côté la France insoumise qui
prend en otage la nupesse avec le
consentement tacite et silencieux des
autres membres de la nups pour traiter
le ministre du Travail d'assassin pour
simuler sa décapitation lors d'une
manifestation publique avec également
des simulacres de pendaison de la
première ministre dans une autre
manifestation qui a été rappelée
oralement à l'Assemblée nationale et de
l'autre vous avez l'extrême droite qui
sous couvert de silence sous couvert de
de
tentatives d'incarner un parti normal
finalement est un allié politique
des facto de la nupesse puisque
amendement après amendement critique du
gouvernement après critique du
gouvernement motion censure après
émotion bien sûr le Front national ou
plutôt le rassemblement national même si
c'est la même identité vote avec la
France insoumise et le populisme c'est
ça c'est ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale
voyez moi j'ai bien conscience que nous
sommes dans une période de majorité
relative et que la majorité relative
implique
d'écouter implique de débattre implique
de trouver du consensus et du compromis
avec des formations politiques qui sont
différentes et qui ont une ligne
différente de la nôtre moi je suis jeune
parlementaire et sur ces 10 premiers
mois j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à
écouter des anciens qui ne pensent pas
comme moi
j'en ai parlé l'autre jour à la radio
dans une autre émission avec un député
indépendant qui est à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis plusieurs mandats qui a
été maire d'une ville moyenne de la
Meuse qui est contre la réforme des
retraite moi j'aurais aimé pouvoir
débattre avec lui l'écouter et entendre
son expérience et l'entendre partager
son expérience avec moi pour qu'il
m'explique pourquoi il est contre
l'expérience dans le département et nous
n'avons pas eu l'occasion d'avoir ce
débat parce que le débat a été pris en
otage par une partie minoritaire de
l'hémicycle qui ne voulait pas débattre
qui ne voulait qu'une chose c'est
bloquer est-ce que Eric oui c'est ça
c'est une peut-être une occasion perdue
du pouvoir législatif qui est justement
été dans une formation assez c'est
inattendu dans la cinquième république
puisqu'il n'y a pas de majorité absolue
donc il pouvait se faire entendre est-ce
que est-ce que vous pensez que le
Parlement a un peu raté cette occasion
le propre aujourd'hui de la majorité
relative on connaît aujourd'hui et c'est
que l'Assemblée nationale a retrouvé une
part de visibilité et dans la vie
politique le Parlement général et
l'Assemblée nationale en particulier
retrouve une part du centre du jeu
pourquoi parce que moi je vous cache pas
qu'à titre personnel le travail
parlementaire est extrêmement
intéressant parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
vote un amendement à chaque fois qu'on
débat d'une proposition noire il faut
trouver une majorité et donc le travail
parlementaire c'est de trouver des
compromis absolument et ça ce qui est
pas une tradition française ce qui est
pas une tradition française mais comme
l'ensemble des pays européens de nous le
font il y a pas de raison qu'on n'y
arrive pas et jusqu'à présent on a
parfaitement réussi cela
le seul texte où on n'a pas trouvé une
majorité c'est le budget mais moi à
titre personnel ça me paraît assez
logique lorsque vous êtes député de
l'opposition oui pas de réseau de voter
le budget il n'y a pas de raison de
voter le budget parce que vous êtes
contre un policier gouvernement et en
même temps si vous passez le terme il
faut bien pouvoir rémunérer les agents
publics et faire fonctionner services
publics au 1er janvier donc il a fallu
utiliser le 49-3 sans motion de censure
sur tous les autres textes et des textes
importants l'assurance chômage le
pouvoir d'achat la protection sanitaire
la loi de programmation du ministère
intérieur on a trouvé des majorités et
des majorités qui étaient larges
voilà un texte sur lequel les Français
nous attendaient
attendez beaucoup de nous
et voilà un texte sur lequel
l'Assemblée nationale mais surtout une
part de nos collègues qui ont
délibérément bloqué le débat non pas été
à la hauteur
7 qui prolonge le temps de travail
64 ans
très de 62 à 64 ans on n'a pas été à
l'article 8 l'article 9 à l'article 10
regretter de la pénibilité
de des pensions notamment des pensions
des personnes invalides absolument des
petites retraites vous mentionnez la
nups certains regretter certains ont
pris ont eu le courage de le dire je
pense notamment aux communistes d'autres
ont cautionné l'attitude de la France
insoumise dans un silence qui
objectivement été assez gênant je pense
au socialiste moi je me demande vraiment
ce que les socialistes font dans la
majorité aujourd'hui avec la nups
lorsque depuis le début de l'année on a
eu l'État d'Israël un régime d'apartheid
lorsqu'on a eu l'attitude qui a été
celle de la France insoumise qui a été
celle dans l'hémicycle il y a quelques
jours le Parti socialiste que l'on soit
pour que l'on soit contre a été dans
l'histoire politique française un très
grand parti de gouvernement vous aurez
des divisions là-dessus sur ce sujet
est-ce que alors évidemment il y a eu
l'attitude de LFI pour tout le mois vu
puis chacun peut avoir son jugement
dessus il y a aussi son entrée trop dans
la technique mais l'utilisation de
l'article 47 1 de la Constitution pour
que le débat soit un peu plus rapide il
y a aussi le fait que la loi s'inscrit
dans une dans une loi de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale qui
peut poser des problèmes avec le
conseiller constitutionnel sur un
certain nombre de de poids de la loi sur
la retraite est-ce que est-ce
que là aussi bon il y a pas eu aussi un
jeu du côté de la majorité pour éviter
le débat on le dit beaucoup on entend
certains qui disent au fond et elle est
fille et la majorité est assez content
que le démon n'allait pas jusqu'au bout
c'est mon devoir de vous exprimer du
coup mon point de vue et d'expliquer
cette position
j'entends tout à fait les interrogations
que je vais vous répondre sur la forme
et sur le fond sur le fond
le texte sur la réforme des retraites
est un texte
budgétaire la question qu'on se pose
c'est de dire est-ce que oui ou non le
système de retraite sera à l'équilibre
financier dans les décennies à venir et
est-ce que oui ou non nous avons les
capacités financières de répondre plus
justement aux attentes des gens je pense
notamment à la pénibilité je pense aux
carrières longues je pense au minimum
retraite on touche à des questions
profondément financières donc sur le
fond le fait que ce texte soit un texte
budgétaire dans le cadre des comptes
sociaux se justifient totalement la
deuxième question sur la forme
nos adversaires nous expliquent qu'on
n'a pas eu le temps de débattre
lorsqu'on prend les différentes réforme
des retraites qui a eu par le passé
2010 la réforme des rives vertes et de
Nicolas Sarkozy qui a passé l'âge de
départ à la retraite de 60 à 62 ans
ensuite pendant le quinquennat de
François Hollande la réforme Touraine
qui accélère et qui allonge la durée
d'année de cotisation sur ces deux temps
de débats le débat a été moins long il y
a eu moins d'heures de débats que le
débat que nous avons eu cette fois-ci
quelle est la différence
quelle est la différence qu'il y a eu
la réforme des retraites en 2010 600
amendements
la réforme des retraites de la loi
Touraine quelques centaines
d'amendements cette fois-ci 20 000
amendements donc 15000 déposés par la
seule France insoumise moi je pose donc
la question qui a réellement la
responsabilité du blocage chacun en fera
son avis est-ce que quand même sur une
réforme importante parfois on a eu le
sentiment que
je parle pas de la majorité pas de
gouvernement avait peut-être pas
communiquer comme il aurait fallu il y a
eu ce fameux 1200 euros au minimum donc
tout le monde pensait que ça irait
chaque personne qui progresse à sa
retraite et puis on a appris donc il
fallait avoir tous ces trimestres vous
pourriez avoir c'est un des points par
exemple est-ce qu'il y a pas eu parfois
quand même des du côté de du soft
peut-être de la première ministre des
maladresses de en tout cas de
communication il y a peut-être eu un
manque de justesse dans la communication
pour communiquer pour partager notre
point de vue il faut d'abord écouter
le temps qui a été pris pour la
concertation
et qui toujours le cas aujourd'hui avec
l'ensemble des parlementaires et les
forces syndicales elle est là à la force
de les baiser avec borne et notre
majorité
ils avaient demandé
d'écouter écouter écouter
lorsque vous écoutez les syndicats
aujourd'hui
ils expliquent contre la réforme ils ont
le droit de le faire mais il y a une
chose qui reconnaisse la première
ministre majorité c'est que la porte a
toujours été ouverte à la concertation
pour améliorer le texte ça a été le cas
sur le carradites haché je ne pas sterme
mais il désigne une réalité sur la
pénibilité sur les carrés longue ensuite
vient le temps de l'écoute vient ensuite
le temps d'exprimer notre point de vue
de sur un débat aussi complexe je pense
qu'ils vont pas qu'on parte principe
simple
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait cette réforme
la première raison
c'est qu'elle est nécessaire
aujourd'hui on a un système de retraite
qui va être en déficit de 12 milliards
d'euros sur la seule année 2027
à la moitié du siècle on sera à 500
milliards d'euros cumulés de déficit et
donc de dettes moi je ne résout pas
cette situation moi je souhaite que ma
génération et les générations futures et
un système de retraite qui soit viable
pour qu'ils soient fiable il faut qu'il
soit l'équilibre et donc
pour répondre à ce sujet on a finalement
trois choix qui sont assez simples pour
mettre le système à l'équilibre soit on
demande aux travailleurs et aux
entreprises de payer plus
je refuse cette option
soit on baisse la pension des retraités
nous on veut au contraire l'augmenter
pour les petites retraites soit on
demande aux gens de travailler plus
longtemps et je fais juste ce point là
demandez aux gens de travailler plus
longtemps ça n'a rien d'anodin
c'est un effort important de gens
mais ça me paraît nécessaire pour la
viabilité du système et surtout ça me
paraît juste
pour demander aux gens de pas travailler
plus longtemps il faut que la réforme
soit juste c'est la raison pour laquelle
on écoute c'est la raison pour laquelle
on concerne ne pas y avoir de
contrebasse
donc mais la suppression des régimes
spéciaux qui sont justifiées la fin de
régime spéciaux moi me semble juste dire
que tout le monde qui a une carrière
complète
gagnera au minimum 1200 euros bruts par
mois Samsung juste mieux prenant compte
la situation des femmes qui sont seules
à la tête de famille monoparentale parce
qu'elles a eu un accident personnel de
la vie moi ça me semble juste mieux
prendre en compte le handicap
l'invalidité des travailleurs dans ces
situations moi ça me semble juste et
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire il y a
quand même un point sur lequel on peut
avoir une interrogation
Laurent Berger d'été a toujours dit pas
d'âge légal je suis peu discuté sur
l'allongement du temps de travail je ne
veux pas d'âge légal à 65 ou 64
au fond vous dites voilà on va demander
aux Français de travailler plus est-ce
que vous auriez pas pu passer une sorte
d'accord avec la CFDT éviter ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est à dire la rue
face au Parlement mais ça on va en
parler
en prenant comme comme principal réforme
l'allongement du temps de travail plutôt
que l'âge légal
c'est parce que ça les Français ne
comprennent pas ça chacun notait dans
son rôle
notre objectif pour voter la réforme et
pour voter la loi n'est pas de trouver
un accord politique avec Laurent Berger
c'est de trouver un accident
Laurent Berger Philippe Martinez et les
autres syndicat pour s'ouvrir sud et
tous les autres joue un rôle fondamental
dans l'amélioration du texte dans la
prise en compte de cas extrêmement
important pour rendre le système de
retraite plus juste il joue un rôle
fondamental en ce sens mais l'accord
politique que l'on doit trouver pour
voter le texte est un accord
parlementaire un accord avec des gens
qui ont été élus circonscription par
circonscription par des électeurs pour
les représenter à l'Assemblée nationale
le rôle de l'Assemblée nationale et en
ce sens prépondérant pour trouver une
majorité sur un texte aussi important
que la réforme des retraites les
syndicats jouent un rôle important mais
les personnes et les responsables qui
doivent voter le texte c'est les députés
et c'est les sénateurs en lien avec un
projet qui est proposé par le
gouvernement et qui est amélioré sur
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite il y
a une question de fond extrêmement
intéressante qui se pose sur la manière
dont on bâti notre système de retraite
l'âge légal de départ il est utile pour
deux raisons il est utile pour donner
une vraie visibilité à l'ensemble des
travailleurs à l'âge à laquelle ils
pourront partir à la retraite la
deuxième raison c'est que c'est un
garde-fou et notamment un
moyen très précis de calculer des
carrières qui sont des carrière très
spécifiques qui dépendent pas
généralement de la durée de cotisation
générale pour cela c'est un âge très
important pour des professions par
exemple dans la fonction publique qui
sont dites actives on peut calculer leur
âge de départ selon l'âge de départ à la
retraite générale c'est quelque chose
qui est technique c'est quelque chose
qui peut être difficile à comprendre
mais ces tâche de départ de l'âge légal
pardon de départ à la retraite et très
important comme signal tant pour
l'ensemble des travailleurs que pour le
système de retraite
au fond c'est moins pour pérenniser le
système de retraite que pour donner un
signe favorable au marché alors si on
dit ça tout le monde se dit ouh là là
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette démocratie
de marché mais après tout quand on a une
date de 3000 milliards de
d'euros quand les
le coût de la dette risque d'augmenter
c'est pas non plus totalement idiot de
nécessite favorables au marché j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour le pour
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre d'Alain main mais
là vous n'êtes pas d'accord je ne me
suis pas engagé en politique pour
répondre aussi à du marché d'accord
même si même si c'est peut-être moins
moins terrible concours de conduit
souvent regardez distress quand elle
voulait faire une une politique
ultralibérale les marchés l'empêcher de
le faire on empêche aussi parfois de
faire n'importe quoi donc qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire marcher
c'est
les investisseurs les personnes auprès
de qui la France emprunte pour
répondre à son déficit et rembourser sa
dette
tout l'objectif de l'un de mes
engagements c'est la souveraineté
nationale et la souveraineté européenne
la première des souverainetés la
première des indépendances la première
des libertés c'est de rembourser sa
dette et c'est de réduire ses déficits
et si nous voulons être souverain ce
nouveau être libre il faut aussi que
notre système des retraites soit à
l'équilibre pour éviter qu'il soit en
déficit ça participe à la réduction des
déficits
alors on en arrive là du système des
retraites oui j'insiste sur un point
nous ne menons pas cette réforme pour
prendre de l'argent au système pour
rembourser autre chose certains
retraites doit être à l'équilibre en son
sein d'accord
pour le mettre ailleurs
là on en est quand même face à face il y
a cette grande journée du 7 mars grève
générale face à face aux autres le
Parlement qui est des chances de voter
la réforme même si il y a eu parfois des
interrogations sur ce que ferait les
députés LR notamment mais
peut-être qu'il y aura un accord
législatif sur le vote de la forme et
puis on a en face la rue
oui on peut se demander où est la vraie
légitimité est-ce que c'est le Parlement
est-ce que c'est la rue on se content on
voit les sondages à peu près 60% des
gens 65 % des gens qui sont opposés à la
réforme
moi je lis aussi qui a 80 % des gens qui
sont favorables à la suppression des
régimes des régimes spéciaux oui alors
il y a 68 % gros des gens qui sont
contre cette réforme mais qui disent il
faut une réforme pourtant c'est ça qui
bénéficie des régimes spéciaux
oui donc moi je vois deux choses
la première c'est que je reconnais au
syndicat dont je ne partage pas la vie
d'avoir refusé à radicalisation que
voulait leur imposer la France insoumise
ils ont droit manifesté il y a des
tensions fortes
mais la manière dont ils expriment leur
point de vue
dans la rue à Matignon dans les
négociations avec la première ministre
porte beaucoup plus aujourd'hui que si
n'avait cédé la radicalisation de la
France insoumise et la nuit baisse on a
d'un côté si vous voulez du député
qui traite le ministre du Travail
d'assassin et qui veulent lui couper la
tête
on a de l'autre des syndicats qui ont
non seulement condamné
cette attitude et qui en plus
travaillent avec le gouvernement pour
améliorer le texte même s'ils sont
contre
moi je sais très clairement à qui on
doit
un respect et une reconnaissance sur ce
sujet maintenant lorsque vous comparez
la rue en fait le Parlement c'est
l'Assemblée du peuple
moi si vous voulez si je suis assis là
si on fait cette interview tous les deux
c'est parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont
voté pour moi
et je leur dois
tout moment
et tous les jours mon obsession c'est de
rendre compte de mon action parce que il
y a des milliers de personnes qui ont
mis mon nom dans une urne
c'est le plus beau des gestes qu'on peut
faire dans une démocratie
et donc on a une responsabilité profonde
de respecter l'engagement qu'on a pris
vis-à-vis de nos électeurs et je crois
que le baba c'est de se tenir
correctement à l'Assemblée nationale
pour porter le sujet
mais en colère de ça c'est qu'une fois
que les gens nous ont fait confiance
nous avons une responsabilité de porter
nos engagements et tout simplement de ne
pas céder aux injonctions de la rue
portée par des personnes qui n'ont pas
été élues par le fait mais comment vous
voyez comment vous voyez le la solution
tout ça parce que c'est vrai que on est
dans la capacité de après tout pour
essayer de dire le peuple enfin
référendum mais comme les référendums on
sait pas les faire des passionnés en
France ça marchera pas
là il risque d'y avoir quand même
une déception si
la loi est votée
la première solution la première
solution moi je le vois en deux temps
c'est l'écoute
de chaque partie de chaque cas
particulier parce que chaque Français a
droit à sa retraite
et ensuite c'est d'être honnête et
d'être clair
moi je soutiens pas cette réforme par
esprit de contradiction
par rapport de force moi si je suis
honnête avec vous je suis bien cette
réforme qui est difficile tout
simplement parce que je suis intimement
convaincu
qu'elle est nécessaire pour préserver
notre système et qu'elle est juste
d'accord mais il y a des gens qui
considèrent qu'elle est nécessaire
pendant trois semaines pendant des mois
pouvoir débattre avec eux mais même des
battre passionnément de les entendre de
les écouter et force cette constater que
sur les deux semaines
on a été empêché dans une grande partie
de ce débat par une minorité bloquante
de la France insoumise et par la caution
silencieuse d'une part de leurs alliés
justement quand il se bloqua je
l'assemblé on entend parler de temps
autour de la possibilité d'une
dissolution de l'Assemblée vous en
parlez entre vous entre député de ça
mais on n'est jamais propriétaire de ce
qu'on a oui c'est bien mais moi tous les
jours
j'ai une conviction qui m'invite et
vraiment c'est de dire vous savez c'est
un peu inverti je le sois c'est
peut-être la jeunesse qui veut ça mais
c'est un vertige le soir où vous êtes
élu vous dites il y a des milliers de
personnes qui ont mis votre nom dans un
mien c'est pas anodin comme geste depuis
ce soir là j'ai une obsession c'est de
rendre compte de mon action je ne sais
pas sur un dissolution ou pas
l'Assemblée nationale tout ce que je
sais c'est que le soir de mon élection
on m'a dit profites-en parce que
l'assemblée sera bloquée cet été et en
septembre tu es en campagne ensuite il y
a eu la raison de l'assurance chômage en
septembre m'a dit profites-en vous serez
mis en minorité et en novembre tu es en
campagne on m'a dit en novembre
profites-en parce qu'à Noël c'est la
crise en janvier était en campagne et là
on me dit profites-en parce qu'il va y
avoir un blocage institutionnel et au
printemps ou à l'été en campagne
je ne sais pas
mais je fais toujours attention aux
Cassandre
oui mais c'est c'est intéressant
justement c'est cassant parce que ça ça
vient au fond d'un sentiment comme ça
qui est un peu répondu que ça va mal que
tout va mal ça va être pire comment
se pessimisme français là
vous le ressentez dans les conversations
vous avez avec les
gens qui voudraient lui avec les opposés
les gens que je rencontre quel que soit
leur origine et
une grande majorité d'entre eux
ont plutôt un certain optimisme par
rapport à leur situation personnelle
mais un grand pessimiste collectif
association collective de la société
française c'est très étonnant ça on a
une responsabilité lourde responsable
politique pourquoi
parce que
le récitationnel aujourd'hui
doit renaître en France
moi j'en suis convaincu et il faut qu'on
parle de nos ancrages
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on est français
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on est français et
que l'on a un point commun culturel avec
le chevalier ou le cerf de l'Ancien
Régime le révolutionnaire de 1789 le
poilu de 1914 et les personnes qui nous
entourent
moi je vois des ancrages qui
dépasse le changement de régime
politique quand les changements de
régime que l'on a connus le premier
ancrage c'est notre état
c'est notre état c'est nos frontières
c'est la place que l'État a toujours eu
et la relation que l'État a toujours eu
avec ses citoyens
la deuxième c'est notre langue le
français depuis François 1er depuis la
Renaissance notre langue contrairement à
beaucoup de pays et le ciment de notre
société et le ciment de notre nation
troisièmement je crois que c'est
fondamental c'est notre cohésion
nationale est notre cohésion sociale
tout notre récit national tout notre
récit politique et bâti sur le fait de
dire chaque Français travaille non pas
pour lui mais pour la société et en
échange la société et l'État lui rendent
la protection sociale c'est le donne des
retraites lui donne son armée sa
protection lui donne un cadre de vie
positif
si ce triptyque est remis en cause
la société française elle-même doute
[Musique]
pour compte ce qui lui est dû
c'est vraiment le coeur de mon
engagement justement je le disais on est
dans un quinquennat un peu particulier
puisque Emmanuel Macron ne pourra pas se
représenter à des futures mandat donc il
peut y avoir énormément d'effet des
séances d'ambition pour lui succéder il
peut y avoir aussi une façon de regarder
ce qu'elle est un peu différemment
peut-être plus difficile aussi de faire
de bien des réformes ou alors on peut
dire au contraire il est plus libre pour
mener des réformes qu'il veut dans quel
domaine vous vous pensez qu'il y a des
réformes nécessaires
moi la première question que j'essaie de
me poser c'est pourquoi parce qu'on m'a
dit réformes c'est un mot que chacun
d'entre nous nous utilisons peut-être
presque pour chaque projet de loi
le propre de la loi c'est d'améliorer la
vie quotidienne de chaque Français de
chaque citoyen
on est à un point aujourd'hui de rupture
parce qu'on voit qu'au niveau mondial il
y a un changement profond de paradigme
tant dans la relation que les gens ont à
leur état au pouvoir et aussi dans
des changements géopolitiques profonds
qu'on connaît dans le monde
et tout notre enjeu à nous quel que soit
la situation politique notamment du
président de la République c'est de
voter la loi le président de la
République c'est de prendre des
décisions
qui contribuent au bien-être des
Français
on est dans une situation charnière
au-delà de sa situation personnelle ou
nous sortons d'une crise sanitaire nous
sommes dans une recomposition mondiale
des forces économiques démographiques
politiques technologiques auxquelles il
doit répondre
et je peux vous dire de la perçu que
j'en ai c'est que quel que soit sa
situation personnelle le président de la
République et notre majorité et je crois
tous les responsables politiques en
général nous sommes déterminés à faire
en sorte d'améliorer au mieux la vie
quotidienne des gens
mais parfois il y a un reproche c'est
c'est qu'on fait c'est celui de la
lisibilité ou celui de la perspective
ou on va parler justement de ces piliers
qui sont qui sont les pays de la France
mais où on va quel front on veut quel
pays on veut
est-ce que voilà il y aurait pas un
besoin justement de redéfinir des
perspectives pour vous montrer justement
que tel ou telle réforme nécessaire j'en
suis persuadé définir des perspectives
simples mais fondamental le choix de mon
élection je me suis permis de prendre un
petit papier avec moi il y a un
administré un habitant qui vient du
pyracite Bernard de Jussieu qui m'a dit
j'ai retrouvé le cahier des doléances
des paysans du village de Guyancourt en
il m'a dit tu devrais aller voir aux
archives départementales
à la suite des gilets jaunes à la suite
des différentes élections qui ont été
menées
regarde ce qu'il dit à l'époque et tu me
feras un retour je me suis donc rendu et
la chance que j'ai eu c'est que
quelqu'un à l'époque avait mené dans les
années 70 me semble avait mené une thèse
en expliquant en allant voir ses propres
audiences donc il a dactylographiés
que disent les doléances de 1789
à l'époque
article premier que tous les impôts
soient payés par les trois ordres sans
aucune exception chacun suivant ses
facultés si le débat qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui chacun doit être égal face à
la peau
qu'est-ce qu'on lit d'autre article 4 la
franchise de toutes les foires et
marchés et l'abolition de tous les
péages la question de se déplacer de se
déplacer librement sans poids avec le
coût qui est moindre on le retrouve
aujourd'hui la liberté de ce déplacement
de tous les Français je vous en prends
un autre aujourd'hui
que les droits de propriété soient
sacrés et inviolables c'est l'article 8
chaque Français chaque villageois des
doléances de Guyancourt en 1789 se
soucier de s'approprier et de ce qui lui
appartenait
article 9 que la justice soit rendue
plus promptement et avec moins de
partialité
l'efficacité de la justice la rapidité
de la justice
je vous en lien un dernier parce que
après je ne vous dérange plus
la paroisse et la commune a aussi c'est
l'article 16 besoin d'un maître et d'une
maîtresse d'école pour l'éducation de la
jeunesse
les peurs et les demandes les
inquiétudes qui habitent les Français en
tout cas les habitants de ma
circonscription
Guyancourt 1789 Guyancourt 3 mars 2023
sont les mêmes et ça veut dire quoi
qu'on est au 1789
il y a un
changement majeur c'est qu'à l'époque
c'était l'ancien régime c'était la
monarchie absolue aujourd'hui nous
sommes en démocratie et notre régime est
une République où chacun de ces citoyens
choisissez représentants et choisissez
le gouvernants ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que les aspérités de notre
peuple du peuple français et en tout cas
des personnes qui habitent ma
circonscription ont souvent été les
mêmes et qu'elle traduisent le besoin
d'ancrage dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure ça c'est la responsabilité du
personnel politique et c'est la ligne de
conduite qu'on doit adopter on peut
parler de la France on peut parler du
peuple français mais la première des
choses qui peut nous animer c'est de
répondre très concrètement aux besoins
des gens sur chacun de ces points là
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
soutiens tous les efforts qui ont été
portés de plus de 5 ans par le Président
de la République pour l'école notamment
le dédoublement des classes en CP et une
meilleure rémunération des professeurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
soutiens profondément l'égalité face à
et la baisse massive de l'imposition 52
milliards d'euros 26 milliards d'euros
sur les ménages 26 milliards d'euros sur
l'entreprise sur les entreprises c'est
la raison pour laquelle je soutiens
fondamentalement la réforme profonde du
ministère de la Justice et le
recrutement massif de milliers de
magistrats pour que la justice puisse
être menée plus rapidement
toutes ces réformes je les soutiens
pourquoi parce que je suis persuadé
qu'elle réponde concrètement aux besoins
des habitants de ma circonscription
justement dans vos relations avec les
habitants de votre circonscription parce
que c'est une des parties de votre
brevasse c'est un mandat national mais
vous êtes aussi
vous êtes présent on est dans votre
permanence
qu'est-ce qui vous dise actuellement ils
sont inquiets il y a évidemment le
problème question de prix de l'énergie
il y a beaucoup de commerçants pour
rencontrer de chefs d'entreprise
en même parce que on est dans une
situation assez
c'est complexe où on voit que le chômage
baisse au rôle l'emploi continue et des
gros problèmes d'ailleurs de trouver des
des emplois qui correspondent aux offres
d'emploi et en même temps il y a des
inquiétudes quand au cou
l'énergie notamment enfin et qui seront
chéris
la première chose qui me disait à vous
tous c'est comment on fait à la fin du
mois
que ce soit le ménage ou que ce soit les
chefs de petites entreprises
les boulangers charcutier et fleuristes
vous savez tous ces artisans c'est
commerçants qui habitent notre quotidien
et qui sont si importants pour le
pour le lien social
raison pour laquelle
une fois que tous ces administrés et
tous ses habitants de disent cela
ensuite on fait des choix politiques
dans l'Assemblée nationale
le choix politique qu'on a fait et je
l'assume absolument c'est de par exemple
bloquer les prix de l'électricité les
prix du gaz
lorsque les habitants me montrait au
début de l'année 2022 l'augmentation des
prix l'augmentation de la facture des
prix de l'électricité oui je voté sans
trembler sans hésitation le blocage du
prix de l'électricité pour tous les
ménages pour toutes les TPE et pour les
toutes les collectivités de moins de 28
000 habitants je les fais la deuxième
chose c'est que j'ai soutenu pour
améliorer le texte et ensuite pour le
porter auprès des boulangers des
charcutiers des fleuristes dont j'ai
fait tout le tour dans la
circonscription parce que c'est mon rôle
les aides spécifiques qui avaient pour
les TPE pour les PME et pour les
entreprises de taille intermédiaires de
mon territoire le bouclier tarifaire
d'une part d'autre part le guichet
unique d'autre part l'amortisseur
électricité et j'encourage chacun des
chefs d'entreprise de TPE de PME et de
TI et leurs salariés à se rendre sur le
guichet qui est ouvert pour eux sur
impôts.gouv.fr tout le monde connaît ce
site absolument
on dit parfois c'est un peu compliqué
qui fait que beaucoup de gens qui
auraient droits
ne font pas jouer leurs droits le
premier truc qui me revient qui est
totalement légitime c'est je sais qu'il
y a des droits qui existent c'est
compliqué mais je sais pas où m'adresser
je sais pas qui m'adresser le message
est simple vous avez besoin d'être
accompagné allez sur le guichet
impôts.fr c'est pour payer vos impôts
c'est aussi pour voir à quoi vous avez
le droit on en revient au principe dont
on parlait tout à l'heure depuis des
années vous contribuez à la cohésion
nationale et à la cohésion sociale le
rôle de l'État et le rôle de la société
c'est de vous rendre dans les périodes
de crise pour que vous puissiez
continuer votre activité c'est
l'engagement qu'on a pris auprès de nos
boulangers de nos charcutiers de nous
boucher et de tous les chefs
d'entreprise et leurs salariés de TPE et
PME
et peut-être
mais peut-être que c'est vrai que les
services publics parlaient de
impôts.gouv.fr
il faut il faut internet il faut il y a
peut-être que le fait aussi qu'on est
plus moins d'interlocuteurs dans les
services publics posent aussi un
problème ça avait été un des raisons
d'ailleurs de la colère des gilets
jaunes à l'époque c'est vrai que là
aussi peut-être des services publics
marche pas aussi bien qu'il devrait la
fracture numérique auquel toutes les
sociétés sont confrontées est l'un des
défis majeur du 21e siècle
moi je crois profondément qu'il n'y aura
pas de liberté et d'indépendance
politique sont libertés et indépendances
technologiques
tu as raison pour laquelle on doit
développer toutes nos capacités
françaises et européennes numériques et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
réflexion profonde doit être menée sur
le lien entre le citoyen et la sphère
numérique et c'est ce à quoi s’emploie
aujourd'hui le gouvernement avec
notamment le ministre journal Maroc qui
le mon voisin de circonscription qui
mène une action volontariste sur le
sujet
peut-être un mot mais très rapide alors
sur le service national universitaire
obligatoire on dit qu'il sera
obligatoire pour les pour les mineurs
enfin il y a un projet vous qui
justement des structures de la France
peut-être de la question de citoyenneté
de favorable je suppose absolument
favorable c'est un formidable outil de
cohésion dès le plus jeune âge c'est un
formidable outil aussi pour découvrir
toute une gamme de métiers qu'on ne
découvre pas l'école c'est une
un formidable outil
engagement citoyen pour découvrir ce que
ça veut dire s'engager pour la nation et
donc je récuse absolument et même avec
un sourire tous ceux qui nous expliquent
que c'est une militarisation de la
jeunesse non ce n'est pas jeunesse c'est
plutôt tout simplement d'offrir un
moment unique très profond à l'ensemble
d'une classe d'âge qui en plus est
mineur
alors un mot sur la on en a parlé vous
avez parlé sur cette chaîne même sur la
mission de vos idées le rapporteur mais
sur les dispositifs de soutien
l'exploitation et à la créativité alors
déjà vous êtes corps rapporteur avec
Sofia chérikou qui est très proche de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon RFI et là il y a pas
eu de nom d'oiseaux il y a pas de
menaces on peut on peut parfois
travailler ensemble oui c'est l'exemple
très concret que je veux partager avec
ce qui nous regardent
que le travail de fond à l'Assemblée
nationale se passe vraiment avec sérieux
et avec respect oui nous avons des
différences fondamentales avec Sophia
chikiro je suis député de la majorité du
groupe Renaissance Sofia Chikirou et
l'une des leaders du groupe France
insoumise que mène Jean-Luc Mélenchon
hors de la musique
mais sur cette question on a des
désaccords de fond sur la politique à
l'export et sur la manière dont on
attire exactement étrangers pour choisir
et pour miser sur la France on a des
accords de fonds sur l'investissement on
a des désaccords de fonds majeur sur la
fiscalité
mais on a aussi trouvé des points
d'accord sur des enjeux qui ne sont pas
clivant politiquement mais qui vont dans
le bon sens concrètement comment est-ce
que cette question s'est passée nous on
n'est pas des sachant sur l'export c'est
des sujets qui nous intéressent moi à
titre personne qui m'intéresse depuis
des années mais je ne suis pas chef
d'entreprise je ne suis pas dirigeant
d'opérateurs publics à l'export je ne
suis pas fonctionnaire dans les
administrations à l'export je ne suis
pas
à la tête d'un groupement
d'investisseurs qui misent sur les
entreprises françaises donc ce qu'on a
fait très concrètement c'est qu'on les a
interrogés on en a auditionné des
dizaines et des dizaines et des dizaines
l'État les administrations les
opérateurs publics et privés à l'export
et les bénéficiaires les entreprises et
leurs salariés et fort de toutes ces
auditions on en a tiré des conclusions
des propositions 30 propositions très
concrètes pas des choses qui mettront 15
ans à se mettre en œuvre on a
délibérément ciblé 30 propositions
concrètes avec un objectif
inscrire l'export au coeur de notre
stratégie industrielle ça fait
maintenant 5 ans qu'on est en train de
bâtir une politique économique qui vise
à réindustrialiser le pays une politique
fiscale ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure baisser massivement les impôts
une politique de l'emploi ont un recréé
1,3 millions d'emplois en 5 ans dans ce
pays une politique délibérée de soutien
à l'offre on investit des dizaines de
milliards d'euros dans des technologies
identifiées industrielles d'avenir
notamment le plan France 2030
quel est le place de l'export qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire
concrètement qu'on va offrir la
possibilité à ces entreprises et leurs
salariés de mieux les accompagner pour
vendre leurs produits qui fabriquent en
France sur les marchés étrangers c'est
bon pour l'emploi en France c'est bon
pour la richesse des entreprises et
leurs salariés et c'est bon pour l'image
de la France à l'internation et pour
notre commercial on parle du déficit
commercial qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
exactement tout simplement donc ça veut
dire que la France
s'appauvrit plus qu'elle ne s'enrichit
vis-à-vis des pays étrangers il faut
qu'on inverse cette tente ce qui ne
n'était pas le cas pendant des années
le président de la République et le
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
Bruno Le Maire on dit très clairement
que le déficit commercial et que la
balance commerciale était l'enjeu
économique majeur de la décennie qui
vient on peut gagner cette bataille
la France a gagné des batailles
infiniment plus difficile que celle-ci
on a un génie en France on a un
savoir-faire unique qui est reconnu
partout dans le monde on est dans
Industries qui est malgré les boulets
qu’elles avaient au pied à travers des
lois qui ont été votées sur les 20
dernières années ont su résisté et on se
produire de très belles choses en France
on a des élus locaux qui sont engagés on
a une volonté politique commune très
partagée à travers tous les bons
hémicycles en témoignent la mission
qu'on a fait avec Sophie la Chikirou
pour résorber et pour répondre à cet
enjeu on a tous les ingrédients pour y
répondre maintenant il faut s'y atteler
et à ma petite échelle
de parlementaire des Yvelines d'une très
belle terre je veux apporter ma pierre à
cette
absente et c'est la raison et peut-être
que c'est la question à laquelle vous
allez venir
seul
[Musique]
la richesse d'un parlementaire c'est sa
circonscription c'est les entreprises
les salariés et les élus de sa
circonscription nous on a fait appel aux
entreprises et aux élus de ma
circonscription elles auraient pu ne pas
répondre elles ont été présentes à tous
les moments de la mission on a visité
des entreprises avec le sous-préfet au
développement économique le président de
la Chambre de commerce industrie le
président de l'agglomération
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et son adjointe
au développement économique tout était
là pour répondre à l'appel pour
travailler sur ce sujet sur la
circonscription et sur le département on
a ensuite voulu comprendre au plus près
les besoins et les attentes de nos
entreprises
elles ont tout été là on les a dessiné à
l'Assemblée nationale on les
auditionnait à la fois ambilatérale et à
travers des tables rondes elles nous ont
apporté la sève de notre mission le
parlementaire sans sa circonscription
sans les élus sans les entreprises sans
les salariés de sa circonscription son
action est nulle si en travaillant main
dans la main avec sa circonscription
qu'il peut mener un travail pertinent au
niveau national c'est la condition
une dernière question elle est pour
parce que ça fait combien maintenant 7
mois 8 mois vous êtes juin oui je
propose
le monde député finalement il est il est
rassant il est frustrant il est
passionnant il est merveilleux
oui il demande une grande énergie
mais il y a des millions de Français qui
travaillent dur dans ce pays soit pour
s'en sortir soit parce qu'ils aiment
leur métier sous les deux et donc le
député travaille pas plus ni moins qu'un
autre
la chance qu'on a dans notre métier
c'est la passion et la chance que j'ai
personnelle c'est que je suis élu sur la
terre où j'ai grandi
mes électeurs une grande partie j'espère
en tout cas ce sont mes amis c'est ma
famille c'est les amis de ma famille et
c'est la famille de mes amis c'est aussi
des gens qui m'ont demandé des comptes
qui m'ont dit je vote pour toi
je te place ma confiance maintenant
c'est à toi de me rendre compte et enfin
le bilan dans 5 ans et bien j'espère que
je serai à la hauteur de leurs attentes
merci merci beaucoup merci pour votre
temps
[Musique]